>> Tucker: WE TOLD YOU
REPEATEDLY OVER THE LAST COUPLE
OF WEEKS THAT THE FAA, WHICH IS
IN CHARGE OF YOUR SAFETY WHEN
YOU TRAVEL BY AIR AS ALTERED ITS
MERIT BASED HIRING TESTING FOR
AIR TRAFFIC CONTROLLERS, ADDING
IN A BOGUS BIOGRAPHICAL
QUESTIONNAIRE TO THE PROCESS.
THE NEW TEST IS NOT ENOUGH, THEY
ARE SEEKING OUT THE UNQUALIFIED
INTENTIONALLY.
BUT EVEN MORE WORRISOME THAN
THAT IS THE FACT THAT THE FAA
APPARENTLY DIDN'T CARE IF PEOPLE
CHEATED ON THEIR ALREADY
WATERED-DOWN TEST.
IN 2016, THE DEPARTMENT OF
TRANSPORTATION FOUND THAT THE
NATIONAL COALITION OF EMPLOYEES
HAD GIVEN THEIR MEMBERS GUIDANCE
ON HOW TO ANSWER THE
QUESTIONNAIRE.
IN OTHER WORDS THE GROUP HELP
THEM CHEAT BY GIVING THEM THE
CORRECT ANSWERS AHEAD OF TIME.
DESPITE THAT NO ONE WAS EVER
CHARGED, AND IN FACT ONE UNION
MEMBER CONNECTED TO THE CHEATING
APPEARS TO BE STILL EMPLOYED BY
THE FAA.
MICHAEL PEARSON IS A FORMER AIR
TRAFFIC CONTROLLER, HE'S AN
ATTORNEY, AND HE'S INVOLVED IN
LITIGATION SURROUNDING THE FAA
HIRING PRACTICES.
HE JOINS US TONIGHT.
MICHAEL PEARSON, THANKS FOR
COMING ON.
THIS IS SUCH A STRONG
ALLEGATION, HOW DO YOU KNOW THAT
IT'S ABSOLUTELY TRUE.
>> Michael: I HAVE BEEN
INVOLVED IN THIS SENSE IT
ACTUALLY BEGAN COMPASS AS I
HEARD ABOUT IT.
WITH THE MERGING OF THE FOLKS
THAT WERE WATCHING YOUR SHOW,
YOU REMEMBER YOU HAD THOUSANDS
OF PEOPLE ON THE LIST THAT WERE
QUALIFIED INCLUDING WITH
MILITARY EXPERIENCE AND AVIATION
EXPERIENCE.
IT ALL OF A SUDDEN WAS PURGED,
AND THE FAA'S WORDS AND THEY
WERE FORCED TO GO THROUGH THIS
BIOGRAPHICAL QUESTIONNAIRE.
SO FOR THE LAST SEVERAL YEARS,
INCLUDING LITIGATION OF MY FIRM,
WE HAVE BEEN ABLE TO DIG UP
INFORMATION THROUGH THE FREEDOM
OF INFORMATION ACT PROCESS AS
WELL AS THE LITIGATION PROCESS.
NOT ONLY DO WE HAVE INTERNAL
PEOPLE TELL US THIS WAS GOING
ON, BUT THEY WERE AFRAID IF THEY
CAME FORWARD THE FAA WOULD
PENALIZE THEM.
NOW WE HAVE ACTUAL DOCUMENTARY
EVIDENCE THAT SUBSTANTIATES OUR
WORST FEARS.
>> Tucker: SO THE UNION HELPED
PEOPLE CHEAT ON THE TEST.
AGAIN, JUST TO PUT THIS IN
CONTEXT, TO BECOME AIR TRAFFIC
CONTROLLERS AND CONTROL
AVIATION, MILLIONS USE IT EVERY
YEAR.
AND YET NO ONE WAS EVER CHARGED
FOR THAT, WHY?
>> Michael: IT WASN'T A UNION,
IT WAS AN EMPLOYEE GROUP.
THE NATIONAL BLACK COALITION OF
FEDERAL AVIATION EMPLOYEES, THAT
CERTAINLY DID THAT.
IT WAS A PROCESS STARTED FROM
EARLY 2012 THROUGH 2013.
THERE WAS A GROUP WITHIN THAT
ORGANIZATION WHO DETERMINED THAT
THE MAKEUP OF THE WORKFORCE WAS
TOO WHITE AND THEY WANTED TO GET
A MORE DIVERSE WORKFORCE.
THEY LOBBIED THROUGH THE
POLITICAL FORCE, WHICH THEY ARE
ALLOWED TO COME UP BUT THEN THEY
THEN CRAFTED THIS EXAM.
THE SCORING GROUP ACTUALLY
PENALIZE PEOPLE WITH AVIATION
EXPERIENCE.
AND TO MAKE IT WORSE, THEY HAD
FOLKS STAND IN LINE FOR THIS
TEST AND THEY COACHED OTHER
PEOPLE HOW TO PASS THE TEST.
NOT ONLY WERE THE BEST AND
BRIGHTEST ACTUALLY BRIDGED
STOMACH PURGED OFF OF THE LIST,
THEY WERE THEN FORCED THROUGH A
SCREENING PROCESS THAT
DISCRIMINATED AGAINST THEM.
SO MOST IF NOT THE GREAT
MAJORITY OF THEM FAILED THAT
EXAM.
PEOPLE WERE GIVEN THE ANSWERS ON
HOW TO PASS THE TEST AND EVEN
MORE IMPORTANT, RECENT DOCUMENTS
SHOW THAT WHEN THIS INDIVIDUAL
WAS INTERVIEWED, HE GAVE A
WRITTEN STATEMENT SAYING THAT HE
DIDN'T DO THAT.
THEN HE WENT TO A VERBAL
INTERVIEW WITH THE D.O.T.
INVESTIGATOR.
THE D.O.T. OIG INVESTIGATOR
ALLOWED HIM TO SEE WITNESS
STATEMENTS CONTRADICTING THAT,
AND THEN ALLOWED HIM TO GO OUT
OF THE ROOM WITH HIS ATTORNEY
AND CHANGED HIS STORY.
THAT IS NOT DONE.
ANYONE IN LAW ENFORCEMENT OR THE
LAW FROM A LEGAL SIDE KNOWS THAT
THAT IS BEYOND UNUSUAL.
THAT'S CRAFTING AN INVESTIGATION
TO MEET.
MEMBERS OF CONGRESS ON BOTH
SIDES OF THE AISLE THAT WERE
CONCERNED ABOUT THIS PROCESS,
AND THE D.O.T. OIG
INVESTIGATOR'S FINAL RESULT ARE
BASICALLY HIS SUGGESTION OR
RECOMMENDATION WAS, THIS NOT BE
FORWARDED TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE FOR CRIMINAL
INVESTIGATION.
YOU HAVE ALL PEOPLE AND
IRONICALLY ENOUGH, THE
ARCHITECTS, AND, INTO MENTALS
DON'T LIKE IMPLEMENTERS AND
FACILITATORS ARE STILL AT HIGH
LEVELS OF THE FAA.
>> Tucker: I NEVER SAY THIS
BUT THESE ARE PEOPLE THAT SHOULD
BE IN PRISON.
>> Michael: AT THE DO GA ALONG
WITH THE FBI SHOULD INVESTIGATE
WHAT WENT ON AND WHAT REALLY
OCCURRED AND THE DUE PROCESS OF
LAW SHOULD REALLY BE FOLLOWED.
THE FOLKS IN THE FAA AT THE
HIGHEST MANAGEMENT LEVELS SHOULD
BE BROUGHT TO JUSTICE.
IT'S BOTH CIVILLY AND CRIMINALLY
ILLEGAL TO DO WHAT HAPPENED HERE
ILLEGAL TO DO WHAT HAPPENED HER
HERE.
>> Tucker: THE AIR TRAFFIC
CONTROL SYSTEM IN THE COUNTRY.
IF YOU ARE BASICALLY THIRD WORLD